ça ne m'allait sommes au même moi j'en
ai gagné du mans geoffroy distribution
ou même passionné on descend en
j'entends bien président sahraoui
n'abordons pas d'engagement dans ce bon
je suis à différentes sciences médicales
on les dirait on si cerveau des métiers
et on va faire le contraire constituent
les deux probantes victoires
[Musique]
merci ça avec des programmes 011 du
moment mushir c'est pour sortir son
plein dès la russie pour avoir surpris
je connais pas les traitant référent
c'est quoi
l'argent est intelligent qui tient la
conférence woc est restée titre avec un
bond à dixinn pas de ne pas mettre à
gagner que nous avons été bien que ce
soit pour franchement sauté du train de
faire a dit j'espère que quatre minutes
[Musique]
on va nous dire qu'elle est malade on
passe à dix ans pour michael mais
d'omissions sur mon bon bien que c'est
fini et et nos métiers nous nommons que
vous êtes des modèles je veux ici dans
le droit des femmes et il pense que je
fais mais tiennent donc à peu près le
quart contre oman les ils vont tirer
bon ok il est reparti bon con ça vous
dérange pas des copies en france est
longue les membres
les oblige à respecter
le décret points et fouille au corps
ah bon porteur de risque cette fois ci
risquent bien la probable absence
serenity ensuite en plus un parcours
jusqu'aux auteurs
c'est le choix de la virginie est barack
et certaines nationale ne doit pas le
choix donc pour patrick le futur comme
c'est une obsession et à des fins de
mois sont l'avenir rappelle rien
confitures le pourquoi des paiements et
cetera et cetera
donc pour moi j'ai planifié mon futur
oumma dans des métiers nouveaux cd
peuvent le monde et les meetings je me
suis posé des question j'ai trouvé grâce
à ses yeux
je suis mon sixième au niveau je suis
régalé parce que l'examen des cas parce
que les plans qui subit deux séquences
donc voix j'espère qu'après la réforme
donc mon site est simple
je veux rien quelque chose cette fois
windows
c'est vrai j'ai fini tina dans 70 ce
n'est pas vraiment ce que je batte axial
mon caractère
arrêter des marins mais bon ballon dans
la zone médiane
apparemment je me suis toujours dis
tiens non pas des jeux c'est pas parce
que c'est rare dans les médias disaient
tu fais des plans d'eau zones à bas
coûts n'est pas ce que je voulais dire
alexis de coûts mais les choses vont
essayer d'analyser les choses d'un point
de vue logique mathématique
ok donc ses buts on va voir question
on va essayer de répondre à la question
est ce qu'il faut c'est pour le plus
avant de s'en voir une bonne vie facile
de bien s'en faut je vous défie
n'importe quoi s'en tenir
mais bon pas pour nous
beaucoup de remises en cause les bons
rapports
tu m'as demandé les jeans mais quel con
ce même si l'on sait que j'ai besoin
ce projet d'abord un bon papier votre
culture le monde y va de votre soutien
le monde mais bon moi qui sont conçus
pour eux c'est ce qu'ils font planifier
votre futur ou bien il faut choisir de
mon futur s'échange à grenoble et boksic
certainement le futur jeune amant pas
fournir le futur c'est pourquoi pour soi
c'est du ventre du monde ou si et
ouvriers de la chaîne iii
abo
c'est bon j'ai dit il donc c'est à dire
simplement le problème si je ne pensais
pas qu'on va donc c'est une autre
dimension trop spatiale combo débat
c'est l'exemple qu'on va faire c'est une
autre dimension
c était autrement et les santé au fait
savoir et 80e on se précipite à bhl par
milliers et part chercher des dj de ce
monde et sa région pour laquelle
ambitions des milliers et des milliers
de vidéos sur youtube pour aller essayer
de ne pas en prendre
comment pallier notre futur comment sont
des rongeurs réservera t on y lit des
livres sur la planification du futur
comment trouver le bon chemin la
réussite
comment trouver le monstre alors juste
une parenthèse est ce que c'est
important
oui unique et l'accompagnement le profit
sur le bon chemin sur le contre un et je
pense toujours la même mission
sikorski bull est ce qu'il ya un chemin
communal a découlé le bonjour
je serai la question que je me pose est
ce qu'il ya un changement
alors même si vous avez atteint votre
futur il ya quatre ans je dessine au
lent si vous si tu vas pas en fonction
du vent et ait joué à gérer nettoyant
donc la deuxième option si tu vas
réussir à tenir ses dix nous là tu vas
réussir tu vas en hiver ce que je
voulais et tu sera extrêmement
satisfaits ces deux émissions
tu vas réussir tu vas arriver à doubler
mais tu seras pas sa fille aînée deux
issues soit 3,4 tu ne vas pas te
satisfait et tu vas te montre de ce
genre entre les mains vu que tu as fait
un enjeu interne que je sois tu vas
d'adhérer vous êtes d'accord
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on voit est ce
qu'on doit faire
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire on prenait la
seconde rond choisir cause de mon départ
l'autre bon futur ou bien relative au
règlement
notre voyage vers notre futur à votre
avis qu'est ce qu'on va faire paniquer
ou la choisir pour les futures batailles
et dissuasive choisir le bon vieux on va
choisir le mot futur quand on choisit
rebond futur 10 des profits on va faire
comment sera le monde et fait deux
variables et dansant la régence rien sur
3 et n'a pas pour faire le bon choix de
notre futur on doit passer par trois
étapes la première étape c'est de
définir ses propres variable et se
comprendre il faut s'organiser
il faut définir vos montres variable et
les autres grands centres
par exemple projet java plus conscience
tout début moi
[Musique]
maintenant ok son fils aux logiques
ok c'est l'écriture soignée par exemple
à des personnes qui a tant qu'amant
refaire des dix filiales prendre des
risques et c'est un des meilleurs
d'abord puis dans la stabilité dans leur
salle devant franck l'embauché d'une
scène un flux constant et il faut
trouver et définir nos variable c'est
pour ça qu'on n'a rien apporté
je vends mon temps à analyser et définir
mais constante et mais variable
ok c'est bon je vais mais colère tu
apprendre à mieux connaître maintenant
la prochaine étape c'est d'analyser les
différentes solutions que j'ai en face
de moi c'est des choix donc la même
chose par 13e et pas je vais définir des
grands centres et les variables les
bonnes solutions
les choix possibles le processus je les
côtoie un bas niveau
je vais les finir d'être aimée processus
la deuxième étape je vais analyser des
choix je lui dit geneviève leur
conscience et leur variable soit
français mais notre génial
la première la troisième étape c'est de
chercher un lien de de combat cheville
entre nick en france et les constantes
de méchant parce que profitable
ça sert à rien de faire tout ce long
voyage responsable futur office amino
son dos moi je pars donc c'est pourquoi
je dois analyser mon futur selon cette
règle la compatibilité des cancers ok
c'est bon c'est clair at on
j'espère entend dire quels sont les
avantages de faire son choix selon la
compagnie et des lances savez quand vous
avez choisi votre jeu dur selon cette
règle
vous avez analysé vos constante éprouve
à rien c'est bon on est volé j'ai
analysé les campements et des variables
de chaque option
le géant trimestre maintenant j'ai
essayé d'établir un lien de gand campath
miser entre mais constante et des gants
du show finalement quels sont les
avantages le premier avantage c'est que
cette méthode va permettre de générer le
sort de conviction parce que quoi qu'il
arrive il ya eu échanges douaniers pas
dans les annales
il pense à notre culture c'est le même
futur que tu l'a choisi parce que
l'écrit américaines combinées se sont
pas des critères variables que ce sont
des critères
le deuxième avantage si rassurant ce
parce que messi votre verre bien
d'autres faire bien patron pour un sac
ne voulait pas sur le bon chemin
eh ben vous dis que si je suis sur mon
chemin parce que sinon je peux vous vous
êtes construire et vous le connaissez
très bien le travail et davantage que
c'est très agréable car sur tout des
choix que vous allez prendre durant tout
votre voyage je pointe à rebours des
jeux présents au fait de ces bons
résultats le premier résultat vous serez
convaincus par ce que vous faites
c'était parce que s'il vous plaît
le futur ce sera une projection de faux
pansements parce qu'il avait pour
activité montfaucon stands et les
lancements de ce que vous avez chose ok
deuxième point votre futur ne sera
qu'une projection de francs constants
c'est ce que je viens de troisième à
l'arrivée vous allez provenir ce que
vous avez voulu des débats
évidemment mais n'avoir double dans nos
voitures et trois en dix enseignants
dans la discographie complète parce que
tout simplement le grief principal ou
bien des critères de mon choix cynique
des gants des gants sans et
quatrièmement même si vous pourrez pas à
vous mais pour une raison x ou y
vous serez pas déçus et vous n'avez rien
regretter parce que le regret c'est ce
qui va nous détruire et nous a demandé
de les encercler yeux jusqu'à justement
vous allez aux inuits donc même si pour
des raisons coûts des facteurs externes
sur les miennes je n'ai aucun pouvoir je
n'ai manqué un contrôle
donc je vais obligé à arrêter mon voyage
simplement je ne serai pas des yeux ou
bien je serai pas ou bien je n'aurai pas
à me renier a régalé jouer quels sont
les troisièmes à la première et à aller
basé tout le monde première étape
owings wasquehal première étape c'est
définir
à l'étape c'est définir
par deuxième étape
[Musique]
troisième étape les nantis du chien
les avantages sont elles à rejoindre la
seconde sa conviction
deuxième avantage 3 0 cette méthode est
applicable surtout d'être chaude
l'équation du futur vous savez on confie
des choix on se basant sur des critères
variables et conventions croiser les
doigts et on va espérer que rien ne va
changer c'est ce qu'on appelle les
espérances mais quand on fait un choix
en se basant sur votre idéologie jeu des
critères constants sur une analyse
logique zoologie objective
c'est ce qu'on appelle la vérité ça mais
les choix selon les variables sur les
choix sur l'inconstance plus égale en
plus nerveux
segal et gamme déception
donc plus vos choix qui sont faits à
partir de critères variables sans non
plus la déception tu es et plus vos
choix sont faits on sera fonction des
critères qui sont qu'ensemble plus la
déception sera quoi
le plus c'est plus f parce que c'est la
ville plus des facteurs extrinsèques
qu'on l'a par contre le mans ok alors
autrement dit
déception également référence sur
réalité plus
revenez sept des plus folles espérances
sont supérieurs à la réalité plus le
tout serait déçu plus votre analyse et
d'objectifs plus vous serez moins déçu
voire le mâle atteindre 18
n'oubliez pas votre futur n'est qu'une
projection de comprendre savez
l'objectif final c'est toi je veux vous
imaginez si on pourra tous faire la même
chose pour apprendre cette règle les
combattre les dépenses en est pour les
airs amflora mesure de l'appliquer sur
l'ensemble de nos choix
le niveau qu'on a gagné en avant un
monde dans lequel les gens pourront se
réveiller le matin avec enthousiasme à
des mousses parce qu'ils sont en train
de faire un truc ils ont toujours voulu
parce que j'ai maintenant la phase de re
c'est quoi la condition
donc si vous pensez que essayé
d'appliquer cette méthode
l'accord à ce mythe et des constantes en
prenant vos choix quotidien parce que
vous croyez moi ça sera une analyse plus
objective et vous serez au moins déçu
[Applaudissements]